on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
well today I'll Piers Morgan has
censored trust doubles down in her first
conference speech as prime minister but
if we are stuck with trust economics why
are we going to fix the British economy
nurses vote on the first national strike
in British history but should life and
death workers be allowed to walk out or
debate that
and Free Speech fugitive Julian Assange
fights his Traditions United States I'll
speak exclusively to his wife
[Music]
London
Morgan uncensored
well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on center today was a big
moment for prime minister Liz truss
after a honeymoon from Helm of the
economy smoldering around her a chance
to possibly reclaim the faith of the
nation in her big conference speech
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time to break away
[Applause]
well moving on up is a bizarre choice
for a soundtrack isn't it because they
certainly are moving up inflation Energy
prices mortgage rates debt not to
mention Kia starters poll ratings also
the people that originally sang that
song All vote labor the writer has been
particularly rude about the Tories and
it contains lyrics about packing your
bags baby and going
well trust his advisors briefed in
advance as she'd arrive on stage to a
90s classic end of the robe would have
been my choice and by the end of it
maybe don't speak the slogan plastered
behind us says getting Britain moving
well it's certainly moving but into a
recession
but to be fair to Liz trust she was very
clear about how she's going to fix the
Unholy mess she has created in probably
the worst first month of any PM in
history
I have three priorities for our economy
growth
growth and growth
grown grown and grown
utterly meaningless blabber but also
rather familiar meaningless blather we
need three things
growth
growth
growth
I mean you know you're in trouble when
you're plundering Kia starma speeches
the dynamic inspiration and for those of
us who were hoping for some detail well
this is about as much as we got
and for too long the political debate
has been dominated by the argument about
how we distribute a limited economic pie
instead we need to grow the pie so that
everyone gets a bigger slice
I love a big pie
mistrust but pies don't grow they're
just the same size that they start as
she did at least appear to have made
friends with her chancellor who called
out from under the large bus that she's
been throwing him under all week
and that's why our Dynamic new
Chancellor and I will be taking action
in three areas
first of all we will lower
hey we tagged the economy
me boom
really
wasn't funny what's the joke
you said people's mortgages rocketing
the bank of England had to bail out 65
billion pounds to save the pension
schemes
pound tank to a record low against a
dollar what is so funny why are any of
you people laughing what is dynamic
about what quasi-quarting has done other
than it's the single most dynamic
terrible start to any charts and ship
ever
he says an awful lot that the biggest
cheer of the day came at this moment
[Applause]
that's right it was for the security
guards kicking out the protesters from
Greenpeace or as Liz truss calls them
the anti-growth Coalition because anyone
who disagrees with her is anti-growth
even though everything she's done so far
has led to the opposite of growth the
sad truth is that nothing has been more
anti-growth than this trust is
Premiership today she basically told us
to strap in and get ready for more of
the same kind of Chaos
she said we'll grow the economy but
doesn't tell us how we're going to grow
it or how she's going to pay for it she
said she'll cut the national debt but
also that will borrow and spend more
none of this makes any sense
we all want and need the government to
turn this around we'd all love to have
gigantic tax cuts but that's not how
these things work in a cost of living
crisis of this magnitude and sadly right
now looks like the best way to get
Britain moving is to get mistrust moving
out of number 10.
well joining me now is taught to be
presenter Richard tyus Lauren
commentator Paula Roan Adrian a former
conservative MP Louise mench well Louise
mentioned let me start with you over I
think you're in New York
um you're very good at defending the
indefensible about Boris Johnson if
you're now shifting gears to defend the
indefensible about Liz Truss
well pears don't you think it's about
time you said come back Boris All Is
Forgiven well you know what I tell you
what on that point there is a poll out
which basically says that very thing
that actually most stories are getting
buyers remorse and which they could
bring back Boris that is how bad things
are where he is a better alternative
it's not that surprising because the
first thing that crazy quatane did
before he announced all these ridiculous
plans was he got rid of the civil
servants at the treasury who know what
they're doing who've got institutional
knowledge and who have been there a
while and I'm afraid to say that
bespeaks a lot of arrogance and the most
worrying thing that Liz said in her
speech today which otherwise was okay it
was a steady the ship speech was the
chancellor and I are in lockstep well
when she finished the pound fell a
little bit more against the dollar and
if she is to turn this around I don't
know if she can but if she is to turn
this around the first thing she has to
do is she has to sack the chancellor I
know that she's very good friends with
crazy carting I know him I like him
myself but although loyalty to your
friends is admirable in most
circumstances it isn't admirable when
you're the Prime Minister then you have
to be loyal to the country first he is
obviously a disaster he has to be fired
he has to go and she has to appoint a
couple I would agree with that I don't
agree with what you just said I don't
disagree with you about a chance I think
he's completely discredited now um but
this idea of her studying the ship it
looked more like she was at the wheel of
a Titanic and this is still careering
into a gigantic Iceberg of their own
making they built the iceberg and
they're now driving the ship into it and
I'm not sure there's much they can do
now to restore confidence back into the
economy and the markets which will save
them from the inevitable holding and by
holding I mean a gigantic shellacking at
the hands of a labor party of the next
election because the polls are getting
scary for all conservative MPS
absolutely agree with you and one thing
the conservatives have been good at is
ripping off the plaster when they have
to and I think in this case they have to
Liz is going to have to do more than
just get rid of the abolition of the 45p
rate that was okay but it doesn't go
nearly far enough she needs to really
listen she said she listened she needs
to really listen and recognize that the
markets thoroughly rejected this idea of
cutting taxes and then at the same time
cutting benefits she can either take
decisive action or I think I hope I
believe the conservative MPS will take
decisive action against her and if
neither of those two things happen then
the voters are going to take decisive
action against this exactly let me bring
in Richard Tice Richard are you going to
try and pretend you thought that was a
good speech I think a very terrible week
um it was entirely in keeping it was
well it was about the best that she
could do look the reality is they have a
disastrous start uh from the end of the
period of national mourning and but but
we have to by the way they have to stop
yeah yeah some pathetic excuse
has repeatedly said James cleverly was
at it again this morning but somehow the
queen dying is responsible for their
cataclysmically budget bearing in mind
he was laughing during yeah that wasn't
weird as well look but the point is just
to correct you about the pension thing
they've actually spent only three
billion they've got a facility for 65
right which they're not using the bond
markets are settling but it is
catastrophic because interest rates have
gone up the real reason the markets took
fright we was because of the
government's massive bailout of the
energy freeze using debt as opposed to
the scheme that I put forward which was
to put the cost onto the producers
that's why the bond markets and all the
markets took fries
where the boss of shell the CEO has
asked the government to tax energy firms
to help the poorest people deal with
soaring bills so no doubt no doubt he's
begging her to win full taxes and the
wording he used was there needs to be an
intervention I proposed in mid-august a
proper full-scale intervention that
didn't involve government debt the
government ignored my plan and frankly
they deserve everything that gets thrown
but what is it my problem Paula about
this is the Optics are so bizarre you
come in you take over in an appalling
cost of living crisis and it seems that
the your priorities are to cut taxes for
the wealthiest people in society to
spare the energy companies making all
this profit any windfall tax to remove
any cap on Bankers bonuses and you're
like what are you doing why why are
these people your priorities and what
about the people at the other end who
are now if they've got a mortgage now
facing horrendous bills which will far
outweigh any saving they make on the
energy and it's not even at the other
end what we're talking about is the
masses here we're talking about most of
the people The Ordinary People of this
world who will get up and go to the
polling station and vote who are going
to risk losing their homes who cannot
afford to to heat their homes who cannot
afford to feed their children who cannot
afford just the basics and this
anti-growth Coalition I make up part of
that anti-growth Coalition the bank of
England makes up part of the Antichrist
Coalition
and shell they make up particles
here's the problem here's the problem is
the Bank of England might be incompetent
as you say but they've had to bail her
out so how can she now turn around and
use them as some stick of incompetency
given her own incompetence they're all
incompetent it's the reality I mean the
bank of England first the scary Ritchie
you know it is look because the bank of
England should have raised rates earlier
but the bank of England on Monday
morning at eight o'clock should have
been buying in the bond markets they
wait until Wednesday For Heaven's Sake
that shows the height of their
incompetence they allowed this to drag
on look they're all they're all clueless
I don't buy the bit that actually Tom
scholar was going to save the world he
wasn't frankly he's old-school Orthodoxy
good riddance you need to bring in some
smart people they had some smart people
and they didn't bring them in but it's
all very well playing casino politics no
it's not very well it's terrible no but
what I mean is it's a real world if it
lands on on the color you bet the
Bangkok right they seem to put
everything on red and it's come up black
and the problem with that is it destroys
confidence in this Administration and at
the top of it you've got Liz chance I
want to show today for body language and
I'm a I'm a student of body language
right I just saw a a rabbit in headlines
I saw somebody who has lost her
confidence she wasn't even as confident
today as she was in August when she was
taking on Richie sunac and actually
sounded quite confident well Christian
has some practice right now she's
realized that the reality of what is
going on and I think she's incredibly
vulnerable having made the classic
mistake that Boris made actually of
getting rid of everyone from the cabinet
is not a yes person to her who doesn't
agree with her out you all go rather
than keeping in a lot of disparate
voices who might challenge her might
make better policy she's done the same
thing as Boris so they're all outside
the tent and they're all attacking her
and I think that's going to be what
brings her down what's happened to her
over the last month or so is that she's
had a reality check she's out of her
debt well we've had a reality check but
but also Paulo she they've made some
horrific mistakes yeah that have
demonstrated their incompetence and that
has basically lost the confidence of the
markets Business Leaders and frankly the
population at large which is a which is
a disastrous thing and and the most uh
tragedy of all of this is that people's
mortgages are going through the roof
Louise mench is she still with us
you know I I I advocated when it came
down to Richie sunac against Liz truss
if I back soon that from way before uh I
felt for a year he should have been
running the country because we need
someone who understands the economy and
economics everything well wait a second
everything he predicted about what would
happen if Liz trust went through with
her plans that she was espousing in the
leadership race everything has come true
he literally articulated exactly what
has now happened I would rather have the
guy who predicts all this than the one
who never saw it coming so why can't the
Tories say you know what we just made a
mistake we're not going to go through
another torturous leadership process
we're actually just going to have the
other guy
I think it was a very better leadership
contest to be frank with you and I doubt
that he could unite the Parliamentary
party personally I supported Penny
Morton who's come out today and said
there is no way that we're going to be
cutting benefits at a time of soaring
inflation and that's who I think they
should go with as a compromise candidate
but I do just want to come back to the
issue of inflation Liz truss sells
herself and try to do today as a
daughter of Thatcher as a thatcherite
well I'm a thatcherite too and the one
thing that Thatcher did first when she
got into power was she tackled inflation
Liz is in fact doing exactly the
opposite to Thatcher's plan she's
risking inflation Thatcher didn't go for
growth and tax cuts which she absolutely
did until she got inflation under
control that was her number one priority
and that should be listening and she
also I've been saying this yeah I agree
I've been saying this for a while this
is not what Thatcher would have done
this position she stabilized the economy
got inflation under control and then
when it was all going quite well well
then she slashed income tax and is then
has then become known as the great tax
Slasher in fact she stabilized the
economy first she also put windfall
taxes on energy companies Richard yes
and if I could say one more if I could
yeah one more thing on that one more
thing on that on that point you said
about the cabinet that she's got a bunch
of Yes Men I think it's a lot worse than
that because she admitted today before
conference or yesterday that she and
quasi had come up with this frankly
nutty uh miniature Budget on their own
without even Consulting the cabinet you
can't blame the cabinet when the cabinet
didn't know and that's why people like
Penny are speaking up now so she's got a
very short well I would say I don't know
if she can I would say what penny Morton
has done by the way is extremely
disloyal to the concept of collective
responsibility the cabinet is supposed
to subscribe to Collective
responsibility not going out and saying
what you would do make it very clearly
Louise is completely wrong about Penny
Morton Penny Morton is the least
understanding of mathematics in
economics frankly of any of the
leadership candidates so that would have
been catastrophic as well they made a
terrible mistake they're not going to
get rid of Quasi they're you know
they're they're very very good friends
uh you know from the from the country's
point of view I Hope they've got to
frankly learn their lesson and uh and
try and restore some confidence but it's
they're finished at the next election
and frankly good riddance you know
there's a new phrase uh Paula which has
now entered the Oxford dictionary as of
today squeaky bum time which is the
famous line used by Alex Ferguson
um when he was talking about those yeah
exactly that's that that's actually the
gallery doing that not anybody at the
desk am I that uh squeaky bum time which
is that moment towards the end of a
football match when things are getting a
little bit tense I do feel that mistrust
is heading into that territory where you
feel like I mean I saw Grant chaps he
said he gives it 10 days basically
determines around I mean that's an
incredible thing for a senior politics
in the same part of the state I actually
has any time to turn it around the
damage is done she's she's at an end but
in terms of the squeaky bomb uh analogy
uh I can imagine that she's going for
rear of the year if that still exists
yeah because where else has she got is
she coming back from this Richard or is
she is she basically I think I think is
her credibility is so short it's really
it's just a matter of time and and the
Tory the Tory MPS will do what they
always do which is I'll make a resource
calculation about their own future and
if it looks like they're all going to
lose their jobs out she goes well that's
quite an interesting one because in
theory they can't do that for a year uh
my hunches they've changed the rules
unless they change the rules but in
which case she could just call him she
could call an election that's her Double
Bluff right yeah they would get
the red wall voting alone has moved
gigantically away from the conservatives
but but for no real love for labor but
for absolute disdain for how the
conservatives
one thing I was struck by I was speaking
to my mother earlier about
um uh Lisa and Andy who on on question
time tomorrow night
um with Lisa Mandy and uh Nadeem zahawi
and a few others Brian Cox so it should
be a live evening but she's been quite
impressed by Lisa nandy and you do some
of the other labor front benches who had
a very competent week of their
conference right so you've got a
situation where it's the Tories the
incumbent government who look completely
incompetent and chaotic and the
opposition they're basically just doing
politics by numbers they've got some
pretty smart people on the front bench
now just doing their jobs and doing them
quite solidly and I think middle England
which is the kind of place my mother
represents I think they're beginning to
think you know what they're not too bad
there's a lot compared to this chaos
it's like the last two years of John
Major and it'll be just just a gradual
drip drip drip yeah and the various
story MPS they're now starting to look
for their future gaps they're non-exact
directorships you know where they go all
of it and we've you know we I think
we're just you know and it's
but actually you come up at the very
first point trust economics look the
growth thing is right I've been banging
on about it for 18 months you can't tax
your way out of a crisis you grow aware
of a crisis that's the first point have
you ever tried to grow vegetables
without water
I know you but the way you water it is
the thing is in a business you borrow to
invest to grow right and cakes do grow
actually not that I bake many myself but
Cakes do grow and so you know you've got
to grow the size of the cake and then I
don't know that's the cake has been made
it's a pie by the way no it's a cake you
originally started talking about it
because you moved to piece I don't know
why maybe it's a bit more soggy even but
there's a pile cake once they've been
baked that's it they don't then grow
again no that's right but you know she's
her argument is that uh you've got to
grow the cake and then uh essentially
everybody get to bed thanks remind me of
a very soft souffle that unfortunately
one little prod and the whole thing
collapses it's like a short break uh
stay with me still ahead of free speech
martyr or a high-tech terrorist who
deserve to be in jail I told the Julian
assange's wife about his fight for
freedom
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh and Paul are
still with me here in London I'm with
Louise mench in New York so interesting
thing happened yesterday we play played
a little teaser Trail to my interview
with the rather notorious Andrew Tate uh
this guy who's been removed from social
media because of his uh apparent
misogyny and so on
um big interview where wearing it in
full on Friday I'm not sure what I make
of it I think it's down to the viewers
to watch it and see whether you think
the punishment suits the apparent crime
but one thing was really fascinating was
what happened
when we put the clip on our social media
platform so it's a got a gigantic
response so other than Jordan Peterson
which has had now nearly 10 million
views that interview on our Facebook and
YouTube platforms and Tick Tock and so
on uh Andrew Tate immediately last night
blew up massive millions of views now
coming in for just this five six minute
clip but Facebook then removed it
as the traffic was flying and sent us a
note saying your post goes against our
community standards on dangerous
individuals and organizations we weren't
quite sure if that referred to him or me
um but we were assuming it's him because
they've de-platformed him and yet there
I am challenging him on his views none
of which to me actually in themselves
constitute being no platformed anyway
then we protested then we get a
notification it's back on Facebook
and then we get another notification
with an apology from Facebook uh we're
sorry that we got it wrong so an
interesting little journey there with
Facebook's
censorship process I guess that there's
a guy they banned from having his own
accounts on Facebook as he has been on
Tick Tock Instagram Twitter and other
platforms and there's Facebook
automatically wanting to ban him
from even appearing on our site even
when I'm challenging him on his views
about why he's been banned and then
rewinding and apologizing
um Louise Mensch this really goes to the
harder thing of a lot of the issues
around big Tech censorship we still have
this ridiculous situation where Donald
Trump is banned
from Twitter for example I don't think
Facebook as well still uh and yet the
Ayatollah of Iran and Taliban leaders
are allowed to have accounts and they're
still active I don't understand the
inconsistency there and I'm not quite
sure with Andrew take white I can't even
challenge him on his views which have
led to him being banned without those
clips also being censored albeit now
roll back with an apology
yeah I mean how are you supposed to hold
the guy to account from what I'm reading
about the previews of your interview you
ripped him a new one I'm looking forward
to seeing that because it's about time
that guy was challenged and yet all this
is doing is making Mr Tate more
interesting more sexy if you like than
he needs to be by saying not only are we
going to ban him but we're going to even
ban journalists talking about him I mean
what is he what is he Area 51 right uh
is it is he classified what is the point
of ripping down everything that contains
this guy if he is a muppet which is what
he sounds like then let's have people
like you holding him to accounts and I
think also practically it's also because
Mark Zuckerberg is cheap it sounds like
it was an algorithmic decision we don't
like Andrew Tate we're going to yank it
yeah and then when you post it they said
oh no are bad well Facebook has got
billions and billions hundreds of
billions of dollars they can afford to
pay some real people to make the these
decisions so that stupid things like
this stop happening right Richard ties I
mean it is it's this creeping censorship
from Big Tech and I've been on the
receiving end of it before when I wrote
a column several years ago for the Daily
Mail website in America uh about Simone
biles the uh gymnast in America it was
quite a provocative column about when
she quit and I said she shouldn't have
quit and so on but regardless of that
the the column got removed by Google
because it turned out nothing to do with
what I'd written in the column but
because something somebody had written
in a comment underneath the column so
the the Publishers were being held to
account for a comment on a column not
even the content of their own editorial
and Google unilaterally removed the
whole thing thus depriving the publisher
of making any revenue from that column
for the period when it was being
extremely at the time well read and I
found that a pretty disturbing bit of
censorship too the whole thing is so
disturbing in so many ways the bizarre
thing is that as I understand Instagram
didn't remove your uh Tate tease no so
to speak even though Instagram is also
owned by face right
um uh by the parent company so that
shows that actually the algorithms have
got no consistency Louise is quite right
here that there should be some smart
bright well-paid people who are able to
make an instant judgment Elon Musk Elon
Musk is going ahead with buying Twitter
it looks like full disclosure I own uh
stock in Twitter so I want to put that
on the table
um but it's interesting with Elon Musk
because he's vowed to root out Bots and
all this kind of stuff that's been going
on with Twitter he's a big advocate of
free speech there is a rumor that he may
bring Donald Trump back to the platform
would he be right to do that do you
think I think he would you can't have
the Taliban on Twitter in the 45th
president of the United States not on
Twitter For Heaven's Sake I mean it's
just it defies all logic uh completely
we have to watch all of this big Tech
stuff like Hawks you've had the shambles
with PayPal last week taking down things
like the Free Speech Union yeah a a
parent group looking after the world
you know they've got a hard job I spoke
to one of the top people of Facebook in
the summer who told me that the sheer
volume of accounts they remove on a
minute by minute basis is enormous
they're really struggling to keep up
with how they they sort of police their
sights and they're aware that their
Builders are wild west and they're
trying to police them but at the same
time when they do over police we'll come
down like a ton of bricks and this is
the problem isn't it because we know
that we are losing children due to the
content that they see online poor Young
Girl Molly exactly and so we are at you
know this and this is the problem isn't
it with social media we are we're taken
to these vast different regions
um in terms of the depth of the
arguments in relation to free speech we
know that but fundamentally do I think
they're doing the right thing absolutely
and have we evidenced that in this case
yes we have what about this what about
this so I I I've talked about this a
couple of times but I had a death threat
made against me and my eldest son on his
Instagram in public not a private
message public comment to a picture of
me and my son right this was back uh 18
months ago maybe longer and I was so
incensed by the nature of it and the
specifics of it and how just grotesque
he was doing on my son's Instagram he's
in his late 20s but he was a bit freaked
out by too that I reported it to the
police
I've got an update today from the police
it still hasn't reached a charging
decision right they knew this person was
months and months and months ago they've
had the phone months and months and
months ago and there's still no charging
decision now I'm a high profile person
who has talked about this in public and
there's still no resolution to this 18
months after a specific death threat
which half they if they made it in the
street would be a criminal offense so my
point is not just about the the
complexity of doing all this but also
the accountability that has to come then
from the full force of the law when
people act with impunity on social media
but then we go back to the police and
fund him because that's the issue I
think that's right that's it I don't
blame the police I mean the people have
been handling it with me are very nice
people but they literally are so strong
but it requires common sense it does
require smart people in the police case
that you know there may be a need for an
extra resource but you can't say that
Facebook and Instagram haven't got the
resource they clearly have and they
should be they've got to apply some
there's a massive difference between
someone like talk to UV having a uh an
open discussion with someone like Andrew
Tate and some blogger from the deepest
strangest place oh yeah he's talking
about Andrew Tate is I didn't know much
about him but my sons all did so he's
got a huge following around the world of
young men in particular and the big
question for him is has anything that
he's done really constituted being no
platform been removed being banished
from from all social media patterns and
I'm not sure frankly after interviewing
him for 90 minutes I I really conclude
I'm not sure that he did do anything
that deserved it you might find him
unsavory he's a big bragging Jack Malad
who talks in a pretty coarse way about
women but there's no evidence of any
non-consensual Behavior a lot of women
have race to defend him no women that
he's been around have spoken out against
him and yet there he is banished and I
see the Ayatollah of Iran tweeting away
yesterday
interesting anyway the whole interview
is on Friday with Andrew Tate if you
don't know much about him you'll find it
compelling anyway is the malicious a
misogynist is he misunderstood is he all
those things you can decide but
ultimately should he be bad here's a
little tease
I believe that me standing up and saying
a man must protect a woman and provide
for her so we need to make sure that
she's safe he needs a degree of
authority I have no problem with no but
no you but people do have a problem with
it and that's not sorry and that's the
world we're in now I'm over here why are
you single I'm not single well you're
not married well if I was married the
last thing I would do is advertise it to
the feral Psychopaths on the internet
good so we agree no we don't yes we do
no we don't fears are on my side afraid
of being canceled along with me being
empty any woman at all not when I'm not
what I'm saying that women are beautiful
and attractive at a certain age and if
you fix the problem in their life
perhaps they won't feel the person no
but it's not a disease but Andrew that's
the situation Andrew it's sympathy one
why do you miss both no because you're
saying being misplaced that's not the
question cheers I believe
like a politician
it's a very Lively watch is all I will
say and I'll be fascinated what your
reaction is when you see that because is
this as an example of big Tech
censorship just because they just don't
really like the cut of someone's jib or
is it more malevolent than that watch it
and make your own minds up the whole
thing will air on Friday we'll run it
for now and then we'll run the entire
thing without any censorship on YouTube
after that he's already blowing up our
in our YouTube uh platform and at the
moment he's allowed to do so it's
interesting how this all works well
coming up next WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange just wanted in the US for
leaking classified documents right now
he's languishing in belmarsh prison
while his supporters fight his
extradition we'll talk to his former
lawyer but now his wife Stella who got
married to him in belmarsh at Liberty
thus we clap for them in the pandemic
that we don't pay them what they should
be paid nurses are voting on Industrial
action for the first time ever a
national strike by nurses but should
they be allowed to do that
we'll debate that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back to peers organizers
now decades as WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange moved into the Ecuadorian
Embassy to avoid extradition to United
States he's still fighting but now from
behind the bars of the toughest prison
in Britain belmarsh to some is a free
speech martyr to others a threat to
National Security they might not speak
to his wife and former lawyer but first
a reminder of Julian assange's story
foreign
story behind the biggest leak in
intelligence history profile on me an
editorial all right
[Applause]
today is an important Victory but it by
no means a racist seven years of
detention without charge
thank you
[Music]
he does not deserve to be in a super max
prison he's an innocent person
[Music]
[Applause]
well Richard Tyson Paula are still with
me because I'm joined by June
nassandra's wife and his former lawyer
Stella and in America former U.S
national security adviser John Bolton so
welcome to all of you welcome to you um
incredibly difficult
way to lead your life your husband is in
Belmont I've been to belmarsh it's an
incredibly high security president it's
a pretty Grim place to be locked up he's
been there nearly four years now having
also had seven years of no liberty in
the Ecuadorian Embassy
where is this going to go what do you
hope to achieve what do you think may
happen here
well Julian faces a potential sentence
in the United States of 175 years for
doing journalistic work for receiving
information from a source and Publishing
it and it was in the public interest it
was about U.S war crimes in Iraq and
Afghanistan and he revealed tens of
thousands of Civilian deaths that had
not been acknowledged before and war
crimes that have never been prosecuted
let me play Devil's Advocate as a
journalist I thought that a lot of the
stuff that appeared in the New York
Times and the guardian and various other
newspapers who acted in collusion with
Julian and Wikileaks over those
Revelations they redacted a lot of the
more sensitive stuff which might lead to
people's lives being impacted by the
revelations Wikileaks didn't they just
put it all out as a journalist you would
never do that so they weren't really
acting as journalists they were acting
as here it all is and work it out for
yourselves whereas the newspaper editors
acted like what I would say proper
journalists should do which is to be
careful about exactly where you put in
the public domain because accept that I
don't accept it because it's not true
Wikileaks did actually redact all of
those Publications from the Manning that
Manning gave to WikiLeaks in fact it was
in cooperation with those newspapers
they told Wikileaks what had to be
redacted and then Wikileaks published it
redacted in fact Wikileaks withheld
fifteen thousand documents from the
Afghan war logs got criticized over
redacting too much in relation to Iraq
and in relation to Cable gate in fact it
was the guardian that published a
password which led to the cables being
published and in fact they were
published by a U.S publication first so
Wikileaks and in the extradition
hearings there has been witness
testimony about people who are working
with Wikileaks at the time that Julian
did in fact take every precaution to
redact any names that could be at risk
okay Ambassador Bolton thank you very
much for joining me uh first of all why
is America so intent on bringing Julian
Assange to unbelievably Draconian
justice of 175 years I the rest of his
life in prison
well I think that's a small amount of
the sentence he actually deserves he's
committed clear criminal activity he's
no more a journalist than the chair I'm
sitting on the information that he
divulged did in fact put many people in
Jeopardy it undercut the ability of the
United States to have confidential
diplomatic Communications not just with
other foreign governments but in many
countries with dissidents people who
even speaking to American diplomats
could find themselves in trouble and so
you know he uh he's been complaining
about his treatment over the past period
of time he's the one who sought asylum
in the Ecuadorian Embassy now he faces
extradition to the United States I
presume he will get due process in the
United Kingdom to determine whether
extradition should go forward and when
he gets to the United States he'll get
due process here and I hope he gets at
least 176 years in jail for what he did
Stella well of course Ambassador Bolton
is kind of the ideological Nemesis of
Julian he has during his time for the
Bush Administration and later the Trump
Administration
um sought to undermine the international
legal system ensure that the U.S is not
under the international Criminal Court's
Jurisdiction and if it was Mr Bolton
might uh in fact be prosecuted under the
ICC he was one of the chief cheerleaders
of the Iraq War which Julian then
exposed through these leaks so he has a
conflict of interest here Ambassador
Bolton
well that's ridiculous I have an opinion
so does so does assange's wife I guess
we both get to speak them uh you know I
think that what she fears is being
brought to the United States and having
Assange put under trial if he's innocent
uh if you can she can at least show
reasonable doubt that he's not guilty
he'll go free what's she worried about I
guess what she's worried about is a fair
trial because it's pretty clear what the
attitude towards him is well let her say
a large number that's fine that
let let her say Julian Assange cannot
get a fair trial in America let her say
it okay well I cannot get a fair trial
in America because he is being
prosecuted under the Espionage Act and
he cannot bring a public interest
defense he cannot say I published this
information because it was in the public
interest
um precisely because it is under the
Espionage Act and it is the first time
that a publisher has ever been published
uh prosecuted under this act something
that constitutional lawyers in the
United States have been warning uh could
happen for the past 50 years and the New
York Times And The Washington Post say
this this prosecution strikes at the
heart of the First Amendment Ambassador
Bob well I think I think they are badly
wrong on that he's in effect a hacker
and a person who breaks and enters into
uh secure information not even the U.S
election prosecuted under the let me
finish now the fact he's prosecuted
under the Espionage Act uh is something
that's been part of American law for
many many years plenty of other people
have been prosecuted under it uh and and
that goes directly to the issue of
whether a country can protect uh
classified information that there's
absolutely no doubt about and I would
say to the esteemed editors of the
Washington Post in the New York Times
when you try and equate yourself with
Julian Assange you're making a very
dangerous gesture because while you're
saying the first amendment should apply
to him a different kind of legal system
could move it in the opposite direction
and put you under prosecution as well
it's a very dangerous position to take
and an inaccurate one they're doing two
completely different things okay one set
of them are publishing news the other
the other is damaging American National
Security Richardson you've been jumping
a bit again in here quickly yeah first
of all it's ridiculous that he's in
belmarsh prison For Heaven's Sake I mean
I just cannot understand that as you
said you know it's it's the most uh the
most high security so that's absurd but
if this can't be resolved and it sounds
to me actually as though it may not is
there not a sort of international
jurisdiction because there was there was
actually International uh important
issues here that do need resolving and
both sides have a very strong robust
argument and I wonder whether it's
almost like a test case internationally
it's really really significant really
important and it needs to be heard I
think in order to get some Stella Before
I Let You Go how is he physically
because he's been in ill health he was
isolated during covid for many months
couldn't see anybody including you how
is he while his suffering profoundly and
his health is declining by the day you
know he's a caged animal and you can
just imagine what that does to a person
he's far away from from me and the kids
he only sees us uh once or twice a week
um and he has there's no reason for him
to be in a high security prison and
actually on Saturday we're doing a human
chain around the British Parliament to
call for his release
Stella it's good to see thank you for
coming in uh it's a it's a fascinating
debate it got us to the heart of where
Free Speech begins and ends and it's
complex it's difficult and there's no
doubt about that but I appreciate you
coming in can I can
Wikileaks released the names of the
membership of the British national party
in 2008. this is not just about what's
happening to Julian Sergeant America
it's about all of us I want to thank you
for that thank you uh really appreciate
you coming thank you to Ambassador
Bolton I appreciate you coming uh from
America too thank you very much indeed
we're coming next week clapped we bang
pots and we call them Heroes but we
didn't give them proper pay Rises none
nurses are penalty thought would be
their first ever National strike over
paid but what about patient safety
should health workers be allowed to
strike and debate with the former head
of the Royal College of Nursing next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Petersburg so tomorrow
British nurses will vote on a strike
over paid potentially the first national
strike in their history but should
nurses like the police and the Army be
forbidden from walking out Richard dies
are still here plus we're joined Now by
Dr Peter Castle the former chief
executive of the Royal College of
Nursing welcome to you uh Dr Carter
people will say look a lot of sympathy
to the nurses I personally have a lot of
sympathy for them I used to be married
to a nurse
um I think they should be paid more
money but I don't think they should be
striking what's your response well they
don't want to strike
um what they need is a half decent pay
award after 12 years of pay stagnation
the fact is last year 40 000 nurses left
the profession and most of them left
because they couldn't take it anymore
and the feeling is if if this government
doesn't give them something
the health service is going to suffer
even more
so they're doing it not just for
themselves they're doing it for the good
of the energy you know the argument is
that if you allow nurses to go on strike
rather like the police on the Armed
Forces if you let them go on strike you
actually put people's lives at risk well
first of all peers there's a lot of
misunderstanding let me reassure your
viewers nurses will not be walking out
of wards and departments and neonatal
units midwives will not be abandoning
women halfway through Labor what would
predominantly happen is that things like
outpatient appointments and elective
surgery will be canceled now that has an
impact and there is a danger that some
members of the public might lose
sympathy and these are people who some
can be waiting months or years Richard
ties your response to this look actually
there's a difference between the police
and the Army which essentially are
monopolies for our security and the
nurses I actually think there's a really
smart long-term deal to be done here
because so many nurses have absurdly
been charged student loan fees for for a
decade plus frankly what the government
should do is cancel all of the nurses
student loan fees past present and
future that is a massive massive I would
also recognition in return for in return
for a decade no strike date I would also
get rid of all car parking fees
absolutely which I think remains a
running saw and Scandal that our nurses
have to basically end up with all these
car part fines when they're racing to
get to work saves lives nurses have to
pay to be trained then they have to pay
to come to work and to park the pay is
not good
um and this government I mean look what
they've been doing over the past few
weeks which you've covered earlier on
this program they were prepared to scrap
Bankers bonuses
um the 45 percent uh uh pay issue and
spare the energy companies absolutely
and what nurses are asking for is a half
decent pay award
look the last decent pay award was in
2008 when myself and Dave Prentice
negotiated directly with Alan Johnson
who was the Secretary of State for
health and we got an eight percent pay
rise never in my worst nightmare last
minute when you have a cost living
crisis that we do right now which is
really acute and it's really biting you
know I had a problem with some of the of
their strikes and not others like when
British Airways crew are clearly had
promises grenade by their management I
was on their side for example some of
the train drivers who were earning 50 60
70 000 pounds a year I have less
sympathy for 10 pay Rises Runner the
country can't really afford this where's
the line with strikes generally well as
I say nurses don't want to do it and
it's very well clapping on a Thursday
night what the public don't realize is
every day over a two-year period nurses
and other health workers were going into
the very places that most of us were
trying to avoid many nurses left their
own homes that didn't go back for months
a friend of mine works an intensive care
unit at St Mary's he left his place in
Brighton didn't come home for three
months I mean you haven't got to tell me
I'm completely on their side I just
don't think it's right this right but I
want them to get money thank you for
coming in I appreciate it Richard great
to see you that's it for me whatever up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
I'm Tony Dunn and this is talk TV the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited
has to be interviewing president Trump
in the open Office in the White House
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk I have no idea what he
did his interview went up I wondered
more rules is going to launch a nuclear
strike on North Korea or open up a sharp
pit that I've then fall into turn out he
pressed it right at the end of the
interview and then walked to Butler with
a tray of carrying a doctor it was the
dark Cooper
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Divya Coley Liz truss
has promised to get the country through
stormy days as she's given her first
Tory Party Conference speech as leader
the Prime Minister vowed to take on what
she called an anti-growth Coalition of
left-wing opposition but admitted her
plans will cause disruption meanwhile
interest rates for a typical two-year
fixed-rate mortgage have reached their
highest level in 14 years financial
information service money facts says
rates are now over six percent a number
not seen since 2008's financial crash
and production on Alec Baldwin's film
Russ will resume in January after the
actor reached a settlements with a
family of Helena Hutchins the
cinematographer was killed when Baldwin
fired a prop gun he'd been told was not
loaded with a live round that's all for
now we'll have more after the talk
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign